LSD basically makes the brain much more
connected parts of the brain which
haven't been allowed to talk to each
other for 30-40 years can talk to each
other again
and so we've opened up I think the
scientific study of things like
creativity this is drugs this is your
brain on drugs
remember these commercials and questions
what does the brain look like on drugs
that's a question scientists have just
now started to answer David Nutt used to
be one of the English government's top
and drug advisors that is until he
started raising some uncomfortable
questions and lost the job now he
researches psychedelics at Imperial
College London and he co-authored the
first brain imaging study involving LSD
we sat down with him at the psychedelic
science conference in Oakland California
where he was presenting some of his
findings to talk about his research the
future of psychedelic science and how he
got fired from his government job for
saying the wrong things about drugs
[Music]
for nine years I was the head of the
group that assessed drug harms for the
government and over that time we do an
enormous amount of research into the
comparative harms of drugs and as a
result of that I discovered somewhat to
my surprise that alcohol was actually
the most harmful drug in the UK and that
the drugs that politicians like to get
hysterical about like cannabis and MDMA
ecstasy compared ibly much less harmful
so then I started explaining that to the
government saying what our drug laws are
wrong you're actually putting people in
prison for cannabis possession is not
fair because our co-hosts were dangerous
and they did not want to hear that and
they said stop saying that I mean isn't
that your job as the drug advisor for
the government quo I thought it was my
job yeah I thought that my job was to
evaluate evidence and make
recommendations and but they said are
now no he's doing more than that he's
trying to change government policy I
said well I thought that's what all
scientists did if if the evidence
suggests that policy is wrong we want to
change the policy but you can't mean it
once you've been sacked you've got no
comeback well of course what did happen
was that it put the whole issue of drug
harms and comparative harms in the
public domain and there was an enormous
outcry and a lot of scientists wrote
petitions saying they should reinstate
me and I became famous and the whole
drug debate went in went what we know
and viral and so for the first time we
actually had a proper debate so the
government shot itself in the head
really because he went from drugs being
something you didn't talk about to drugs
being something everyone wanted to talk
about the UK's chief drugs adviser
professor David Nutt has been sacked by
the Home Secretary Allen Johnson has the
Home Secretary scored an own goal do you
think tonight not by sucking you in this
way and giving you the oxygen of the
publicity that we're giving you it's a
bad day for science that that government
scientist government advisors cannot
share their genuine concerns about the
misrepresented representation of science
in legislation why was that such a taboo
thing to say there are some things which
are kissed you know you can't have a
what you might call a balanced debate
because everyone has a strong view and
and drugs are bad drugs about what
on drugs we've got to get rid of drugs
so and that was our policy is the same
way it's been American policy
so anyone challenging that was actually
really cutting to the heart of this or
the prejudices which underpin the
British establishment and it went right
through government it went certainly
through both the right wing of the
left-wing parties it's my understanding
that the u.s. drug policy really drives
a lot of policy in other countries could
you speak to that as someone involved in
the the European drug policy US policy
on drugs was basically rolled out across
the world through the United Nations the
u.s. said jump we said how high sir
every single drug policy in Britain was
driven to comply with American policy
and I know that I know that there were
there were drugs which were not
controlled in Britain like cat and I
know that the US government pushed and
pushed and pushed and put on our
government to eventually get cat bound I
managed to hold that back actually until
I was sacked we we didn't make it
illegal but eventually they gave in and
you're first and foremost a drug
researcher and you just completed some
very interesting research in conjunction
with the Beckley foundation it was a
brain imaging study could you tell me
how that study was structured so LSD a
fascinating drug in the nineteen fifties
and sixties it was installed the world's
problems the National Institute of
Health in America funded 140 separate
studies on LSD we gave them a small dose
of LSD this is the revolutionary drug
and then as soon as it started to being
used recreationally it suddenly became
the evil drug they got banned now since
then there's never been a single study
of LSD in America and has never been an
imaging study of LSD now as a scientist
as a psychiatrist a drug that has such
profound opportunities to change the way
for instance people are addicted seemed
to me we must study it so having done
studies with a sort of simpler or less
threatening psychedelics undecided much
of mushroom juice we decided it was time
to bite the bullet and do the first
brain imaging study of LSD we saw
effects which was somewhat similar to
what we'd seen with psilocybin but more
profound as you might expect because LSD
has a very profound effect on
many aspects of brain injury and the key
messages are that LSD breaks down the
normal structure of brain integration
our brains are trained over decades to
do things exactly the same way as
everyone else and exactly the same way
every day every hour every minute every
second and those structures we thought
were hardwired but it turns out they're
not a hardwired they can be disrupted by
LSD when an LSD basically makes the
brain much more connected parts of the
brain which haven't been allowed to talk
to each other for 30 40 years can talk
to each other again huge amount of
crosstalk so we call this the entropic
brain or the much more flexible brain
and and we think that's what underlies
the experiences that people have during
the trip we've got good evidence for
that but also explains why afterwards
people often feel different and better
because they've been allowed to the
brains been allowed to work in a
slightly different way for the first
time perhaps ever when people were
closing their eyes the part of the brain
that's associated with vision was
actually still active could you tell me
what you take from away from that here's
what we showed was that this so-called
near the the complex visual
hallucinations that people see
everything turns into vibration like
everything is falling apart and I
see all the atoms in everything under
psychedelics it close our eyes and they
say yeah it's like films going on in
front of their eyes even though their
eyes are closed and we discovered why
that is it's because normally I close my
eyes and there's very little activity in
my visual cortex and there's no activity
linking the visual cortex to the rest of
my brain but under LSD the visual cortex
was connected to every part of the brain
there was cross talk and of course
cross talk for the visual system is
visual talk so that's why you have these
fascinating complex interesting images
if one of the big takeaways from this is
that on LSD the brain different parts of
the brain that don't usually work
together suddenly somehow connected what
does that mean where does that take us
what questions should we now be asking
that we have that information well I
think what's fascinating about it is it
doesn't just explain a psychedelic state
but it also helps us make sense of why
drugs like LSD can change the way people
behave in the long term as there were
six trials in America for LSD to be used
to treat alcoholism in fact the founder
of AAA Bill Wilson he got his liberation
from his alcoholism the chains that held
him to his drink were broken by a
psychedelic experience he became a
profound enthusiast for LSD and he
pioneered these six trials of using LSD
for alcoholism it works people are much
less likely to relapse back to drinking
after they've had a psychedelic
experience because they can see there's
a world out there which isn't all about
the bottle how difficult or easy was it
to study this in the first place
well it wasn't easy but because it was
an experiment on normal volunteers it
was a lot easier than doing it in
patients so the big challenge then is
doing that or now is to go from these
interesting studies in normal volunteers
and take them into patients that becomes
a lot more complicated because an
experiment is controlled by a different
kind of ethics than a medicine at this
conference we've heard researchers talk
about some potentially promising results
using psychedelics to treat things like
PTSD depression anxiety do the brain
scan
that you did offer any clue as to why
psychedelics seemed to offer some relief
to these kind of conditions psychiatric
disorders say like depression or PTSD
exists because people cannot disengage
they get locked into a former thinking
depressed people keep thinking negative
thoughts
I made a mistake I was a bad mother I
made a mistake over there bad person
they can't disengage those thoughts PTSD
people can't disengage from the memory
and over time those circuits in the
brain become completely self determining
they just go on and on and on even if
the person wants to stop them and they
can't and I think the disruption of
circuits is the the breaking down of the
these regimented silos of function of
the brain by psychedelics is one
explanation as to why people can escape
from those underlying disorders some
critics might think why study
psychedelics at all we have
pharmaceuticals that treat anxiety
depression that are specifically
designed to help with these disorders
why open this can of worms and study
psychedelics at all yeah that's a really
important question and the people who
are against psychedelics often say then
we don't need it well we good
we got good treatments well the truth is
we don't have very good treatments Oh
half of all people who are treated with
antidepressants don't respond into the
first dose to get 90% responded you've
got to usually have it two or three
trials so there are people that don't
respond and never respond so there's an
opportunity for them disorders like it
alcoholism response rates like ten
percent not 80 percent so there's a huge
unmet need that's the first thing second
thing is these are fundamental states of
altered consciousness I would argue the
greatest goal for science is
understanding the human brain you've got
you can't understand the human brain if
you don't understand how the human brain
is different when it's on a psychedelic
it's it's not to Mike to me this is one
of the most fundamental questions of
understanding the brain do you think
that psychedelics could offer a
scientific glimpse into the fun
of consciousness it's not the conclusion
I've come to from our work is it there
are at least two forms of consciousness
there's a consciousness which most
people talk about when they talk about
consciousness is whether you're awake or
asleep whether you actually know what
you're doing
whether you can remember what you're
saying you know whether you're you've
got self-awareness
that's one content and we know what
drives that that's driven by
neurotransmitters called glutamate and
GABA but there's another form of
consciousness and this is what
psychedelic psychedelics change the
nature of consciousness not the amount
of it but the content it's a completely
different axis of brain function and
that's driven by serotonin or sir the
serotonin receptors is psychedelics work
on and that is fascinating to me and I
think that axis is actually an axis that
scientists don't know about because
that's not the scientific Isis that's
the axis they're artists creative people
work on if poets painters use it it's
you know scientists think very linearly
but this is a nonlinear kind of
experiential thinking and so we've
opened up I think you know the
scientific study of things like
creativity and as you mentioned before
back in the 50s and 60s these were
questions that started to be explored
and then there was this long period that
coincided with the war on drugs where it
just was not explored and now people are
starting to pick these questions back up
again and start asking them again this
conference were attending right now has
been around since 2010 and back then
there were only a few scientists
actually running studies you were one of
them now it seems like it's spread
there's more people the studies are
getting bigger and bigger could you give
us just a lay of the land where is
psychedelic science at this moment it's
entering the mainstream it's just so
it's like going to college it's just
hidden
it's a freshman it's just getting there
in the first term people are seeing it
and say oh well it's it's not killing
people it's actually giving us
interesting insights into the brain it
may be offering new treatments the next
stage is getting what you might call the
mainstream scientists say we can
progress our science more if we use
these drugs so that's going to be the
next
big hike and maybe in four years time we
will see another big expansion I mean
the science here compared before years
ago is it's five times more and maybe in
five years time it'll be 25 times are
there any policy changes either here in
the United States or in Europe that
would enable this to proceed even more
oh yes I mean it's still very difficult
these drugs are all stuck in actually
what's called schedule 1 under the UN
conventions under the USA well we've got
to get him out of schedule 1 we got to
put them in schedule 2 or any other
schedule which allow scientists to work
with them without being treated as if
they're criminals and how would you
envision these types of drugs being
integrated into society or or the
medical establishment these are the
drugs which bring together psychiatry
and psychology these drugs are not drugs
you take every day to hold at bay and
your depression or your anxiety these
are drugs which you use with a
psychotherapist to change the way you
deal with life and that way you get
mastery over your anxiety depression so
I see these drugs as being enormous ly
powerful ways of bringing psychotherapy
and medicine together and that I think
is going to be a it's going to be a huge
element of psychotherapy and futures
gonna be drug assisted psychotherapy is
going to be the great advance in the
next 20 years
[Music]